Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
Well listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. Whether it's a family member, listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. Whether it's a family member, friend or furry companion joining your summer road trip, enjoy the peace of mind that comes with Volvo's legendary safety. During Volvo Discover Days, enjoy limited time savings as you make plans to cruise through Muskoka or down Toronto's bustling streets. From now until June 30th, lease a 2025 Volvo XC60 from 1.74% and save up to $4,000. Conditions apply. Visit your GTA Volvo retailer
or go to volvocars.ca for full details. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello.
Hi there. Welcome to Office Ladies 6.0. Today we have a really special episode. I know we say that a lot, but I love this one. We've always wanted to do an episode around best friendship. And this is in honor of Best Friends Day. That is June 8th. Yes. National Best Friends Day is this Sunday, June 8th.
And we thought it would be fun to celebrate. So we asked you all to write in about your best friends. And we're going to share some of your letters. They were so wonderful to read. If you want to be in a good mood, they should put together a book of just people sharing a story about their best friend because it made me so happy. And also, Angela did a little deep dive on office friendships, but I thought I could kick things off with some stats about Best Friends Day. You know I love a stat.
Did you know there are actually two Best Friend Days? No. One is national and one is international. Okay, that's always a little confusing, you know, if you're on the social media and you do the hashtag and you see people doing National Best Friends Day or whatever it is, National Cat Day. You did international and then you're like, oh crap, which one is it? Well, I'll tell you now. OK. This Sunday, June 8th, is National Best Friends Day.
And that was established in nineteen thirty five by our United States Congress. How about that? I didn't even know that they were the ones who did that. Yeah. They wanted to honor the bonds of friendship and recognize the positive impact that friends have on our lives. And they chose June 8th because it is generally
a time of good weather across the whole country, making it a pleasant time of year to spend time outdoors with your friends. So I think they're wanting you to get outside, everybody. And do something with your BFF. Exactly. Then in 2011, the United Nations declared July 30th as International Friendship Day.
And this was to recognize the importance of friendships in promoting peace and understanding among communities and nations. Well, I like both of those. And then, you know, there's a lot of ways you can celebrate. That's Friends Day this Sunday. But Cassie, I think you would like this way. The New York Public Library made a list of 15 novels
about friendship to read with your bestie. That sounds awesome. Yes. They said these novels feature a range of friendship stories from lighthearted and affirming to explorations of how friendships can break apart and come back together. So we can put a link to them in stories. Yes, please.
Mm-hmm. Well, you know, it's my belief that one of the reasons the office was such a huge success and continues to be is because at its core, it's centered around friendships. Mm-hmm. I mean, I think maybe Michael said it best. The people that you work with are just, when you get down to it, you're very best friends.
Aw, I know. And you know, according to the internet, and there are a lot, a lot of articles about the friendships that are on The Office, but here is one that lists the 10 best friendships in their opinion. Ready? Okay. Number 10, Aaron and Phyllis.
Oh yes. Yeah, they were very sweet. Number nine is the only threesome, Oscar, Angela, and Kevin, best friends. Sure. Number eight, Jim and Michael. Number seven, Aaron and Nellie. Number six, Jim and Pam.
They did start as good friends. Sure. Number five, Phyllis and Stanley. I mean, come on. Yeah. Right? Number five, Phyllis and Stanley. I mean, come on. Yeah. Right? Number four, Phyllis and Angela. Were listed as friends.
Yes. Huh. I know. Maybe more like frenemies for those two. A little bit. Number three, Dwight and Pam, which I love. Dwight calls Pam his best friend. Yes.
Number two, Michael and Dwight. And I would say yes. I mean, that's who Dwight wanted to be his best friend. Yes. Number two, Michael and Dwight. And I would say yes. I mean, that's who Dwight wanted to be his best man. Exactly. Number one on the list of best friends at the office. Any guesses? No. Who's left? Is it Kelly and Ryan? That's the only person I could think of. No.
Such a strange relationship. Everyone unanimously online said the number one best friendship on The Office. Michael and Holly? No, but that's good, Sam. That's really good. Jim and Dwight. I know, that's what they said. They had their ups and downs, but in the end, Jim says, oh my gosh, remember that line?
He's like, I can't believe I'm saying this. I miss Dwight. I mean, they sort of had this weird dude on and off again friendship, but this is up for discussion because I feel like they left a few really big ones off the list. I think Andy and Daryl became good friends. Pam and Michael.
Yes. Pam and Michael. Thank you. Yes. And then, you know, I do like that they say Angela, Oscar and Kevin, but I think Angela and Oscar had their own true friendship. Yes, I agree. And then I would say they left off one. If they're going to put Phyllis and Angela on there, I think there's a
frenemies category for Angela and Pam. But see what I mean? There's so many like friendships that grow over the years of the show and people watch that and they feel it. And I think it's so wonderful that one of the biggest takeaways from watching The Office are these friendships that people connect to.
And the friendships represent the very wide range of friendships. This is true. Which includes, I think, the category of frenemies, or it includes, like, you're sort of like, how did this person become my friend? But they are, you know? Like, it kind of covers all the different categories.
Or the friend that drives you crazy and you prank, but you end up planning their bachelor party. Exactly. Well, we got a letter, speaking of frenemies, that I wanted to read. It's from Alison S. in Edmonton, Canada, who said, My best friend is named Lauren. We worked together as dance teachers.
When she was first hired, I did not like her. She was given some classes I wanted to be teaching, and I felt an instant rivalry. Luckily with time, her charm cleared away any thoughts of rivalry and forced me to admit she was awesome, and I was thrilled when it seemed we could instead become friends. Our friendship took off when we helped each other
box-dye our hair in her bathtub and realized we both did a terrible job. Oh my gosh. We had splotchy hair color for weeks. And our connection solidified when we took a work trip to Disney World and were paired together for everything from rides to sharing a bed. When she got married in a small family-only ceremony, I was asked to be there as the photographer. I have zero photography experience.
Oh. And felt so lucky to be included in the day. Her husband agreed that there was no way I could miss it. They've moved to Seattle now, and while the distance is so hard, we used to live across the street from each other. We're still best friends and have video chats and voice memos to tide us over in between visits. She's changed my life forever.
We both love office ladies and have frequently compared our friendship to Jenna and Angela. Aw. I love that they started kind of as frenemies. Yeah. I love their whole story about them dying their hair. Being all patchy.
Yes. I also love that they stay in touch with voice memos and video chat because there's been many times in our lives and our our friendship, when we weren't in the same city. And we did that. And I knew your whole life. Because we were so dedicated to sharing and keeping each other in the loop. And that's so special. So cool. I loved it. Well, up next, I have a fun thing for us to do. And you guys can do this with us. I'll put a link in stories.
But BuzzFeed did an online quiz to determine, quote, "'Who would be your best friend at the office if you worked at Dunder Mifflin?' Oh, so, all right. How do we do it? Well, everyone go to their phones. I am texting you a link. We all have to do it individually,
and then we have to share our answer. I'm gonna to read the questions that we're all going to do out loud so people will know. First one, what do you do in your free time? The choices are self-defense lessons, hang out with friends, doodle at a cafe, illegal stuff, cook, perfect my comedy routine, shop, or yoga class. Okay. I did it. Okay, next one, ready?
Mm-hmm. How would you describe yourself? Talented, above average, relaxed, inspirational, cool, resourceful, sweet, smart. Okay. All right, what is your place in the office? Are you the moral support, the queen, the best, the boss, the prankster, the snacker, the comedian, the glue? Okay, Angela, I need to know what you're pressing.
Why? Because I just need to know the answer. I need to know your assessment of yourself on this question. Okay. I would say I'm the glue. Sam, Cassie, how do we feel about her answer I would say I'm the glue. Sam, Cassie, how do we feel about her answer? I put I'm the glue. I put I'm the glue.
Oh my gosh, I'm the queen. But Angela, I had you as the snacker. Oh, you could have put... I probably put you for moral support. Thank you. I would have thought of you as moral support or the snacker, but I've decided to be the queen. That's good. Well, the queen in three glues is perfect. Is that how we do
Office Ladies? That keeps us all going. Okay. What's your dream job? Model, actor, multimillionaire, athlete, CEO, painter, entrepreneur, or vocalist. Okay. I put entrepreneur. Are we sharing now? Why not? It makes it more interesting, I think. Okay. Sam, what did you put? Athlete. Cassie? Athlete.
I put athlete. Who am I? I am the outlier of this group. Who am I? I am the outlier of this group. Favorite subject, drama, robotics, physical education, art, after school clubs, school? Band and lunch. I'm going to put drama. I put drama as well. Art. I put drama. Okay. I like it. Pick a hobby, internet trolling, comedy, competitive eating, running, programming, debate,
volunteering, yoga. I put internet trolling. Oh, Jenna. I'm kidding, I put yoga. Oh my gosh, I found out who I am. Oh my God, I found out who I am. I found out who I am. Okay. I kind of found out who I am. I found out who I am. Okay.
I kind of already knew who I was gonna be paired with and it makes complete sense. Okay, go Sam. I am with Pam. Me and Pam could take art lessons together. We're both kind and have a great sense of humor. I like that. Sure.
Cassie, who are you? Michael. You and Michael probably met at an improv class, which you both failed. You love to make people laugh. You both failed probably met at an improv class, which you both failed. You love to make people laugh. You both failed. We definitely did. Mike doesn't make any sense to me. Maybe I hit a wrong button. Jim. You're Jim?
It says you and Jim would be best buddies. You love to prank your coworkers. I do not. You hate pranks. I hate pranks. And you like to relax with your family at the end of the day. That part's true. Well, and you are the likable everyman of the Office Ladies group, Angela. Well, okay. So that tracks. Guess who I'm friends with.
Wait, wait. Ryan, entrepreneur. I'm with Jan. Oh! I'll take it. I'll take it. That's a good one. Yeah.
Oh my goodness, that was so fun. I'll take it. I'll take it. That's a good one. Yeah. Oh my goodness. That was so fun. Okay. I'll put the quiz in our stories too. Well, listen, before we go to break, I wanted to share something. This is a personal share. I want to share that I am on the cover of USA Today's
and Media Planet's Future of Cancer Care campaign. It's like a little magazine, you little magazine that they put inside the newspapers. I'm on the cover. Wow. It's in honor of National Cancer Survivors Day, which was this past Sunday, June 1st. I spoke about my journey and I do that really just in hopes that it might bring comfort to others. They asked me for a photo for the cover
and I didn't know what to give because I haven't done a photo shoot since my hair fell out and it started growing back. I did a picture that Josh took of me when I announced, but I didn't have any other pictures. But then I remembered I did have this one picture that I took, it was when I was doing my campaign for screening time off.
I pulled the photographer aside and I said, I'm getting my port out in two weeks and I have not taken a picture with it because it's like a thing. Like I feel conflicted about it. I had this very like love hate relationship with this port. It's visible. Yeah. And it's not gruesome. It's not grues this port, it's visible, yeah, and it's not gruesome.
It's not gruesome, but it's definitely, you know that there's something there, and your shirt's covered it, but it would be visible to the eye. Yes, it's like a bump under the skin. And so I showed it, and he took a photo of me, and that's the picture that I shared with them. And it was an important thing for me to have.
And then it became kind of an important thing for me to share. I think, I hope that anyone who is going through that will just maybe, I don't know, find something in that picture. Yeah, you know, I was with you when you had it removed and that was emotional Yeah, you know, I was with you when you had it removed and that was an emotional day for you. That was such a book into such a journey you had been on.
Yeah. And I think that's wonderful that you shared that, Jenna. Yeah, I mean, that's a nice share and on our best friend's day, Lee was away shooting his movie in Oklahoma, but they said they could schedule me to get my port out. And Angela, I said to you, I said, well, I guess I'm gonna have to put this off
for like two months. I'm gonna have to have this port in me because Lee's not home. And you said, oh no, sweetie. No, we're getting that done. She's like, I've listened to you for one year about this thing. I will get you to the hospital.
And I had other moms who each took my kids after school and let them spend the night so that I could recover. And it was just, you know, again, friends coming together. The community of friendship, yeah. Who made that happen for me. And now it's out and I have this, I have a scar, which I knew I would have. And I assumed that it wouldn't bother me.
I thought, I don't care. I have tons of scars from my surgery, from under my arm, around my breasts, I have scars, and none of them bother me. So I just assumed that the port scar wouldn't bother me, and I don't like it. You don't like it. I don't.
And some people will get like a tattoo over it. Have you considered getting a tattoo? I don't want a tattoo over it. Have you considered getting a tattoo? I don't want a tattoo over it. I feel like that's just gonna make me see it more somehow. But you did consider getting a tattoo. I did consider getting a tattoo. Just not there, but just to sort of like... In honor of this experience.
Yes. But then I got a fake tattoo for Lee's movie, and I didn't like my fake tattoo. Like, I liked it, but I didn't like that there was, like, something that kept catching my eye. What was your tattoo gonna be? Well, I thought that I might want to get a little drawing of the antique bell
that I rang after I finished chemo. Oh, OK, I like that. Yeah. Yeah. Or a butterfly. These were my two options. But I'm getting neither, as it turns out. And I'm also not getting a tattoo over my port scar.
But yeah, it's just that, like, all the other scars, I can avoid them somehow visually. Like, I don't see them, but this one, every time I get out of the shower, there's porty scar. And then, like, I wanted to wear a sundress when we went to Hawaii and it's like, there it is. And I just let it hang out. Like I'm not gonna like change how I dress
or change anything because it's there, but it bumps me. And I don't know, maybe that'll go away eventually. And I know that a lot of people try to pump me up and they're like, it's your battle scar. You're a warrior. And I'm trying to frame it that way in my head. You know, I just think it's new. And you don't love change.
Like why do you need a little bit of time? I guess I do. And you'll have time with it and it'll be fine. You'll get used to it. Well, anyway, you can look for the magazine inside of USA Today. It came out in Chicago this past weekend. It's going nationwide this coming weekend,
but you can also find it online. We'll put a link to the article in our show notes. And Angela, will you swipe it up in our stories? Of course. I also have it up in our stories? Of course. I also have it linked in my bio on Instagram, so if you have someone going through a cancer journey, maybe it'll be of service to them. Well, I just love all of that.
And you know what, we're gonna take a break, and when we come back, we're gonna share our very first friendship stories. And some of yours. Yes. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady, did you see that hilarious Saturday Night Live sketch they did about men's health and mental health where like in order to trick men into
taking care of themselves, they made a medical clinic that is like a podcast, like a dude bro podcast. Oh my gosh, it's so funny. But it's also because it's kind of true. Men are often reluctant to take the time to dig into their mental health. I've got a stat for you.
Six million men in the US suffer from depression every year and it's often undiagnosed. So listen, if you're a man and you're feeling the weight of the world, we would like to encourage you to talk to someone, a friend, a loved one, a therapist. Maybe you wanna give BetterHelp a try. As the largest online therapy provider in the world,
BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. The new BMO VI Porter MasterCard is your ticket to more. More perks. More points, more flights, more of all the
things you want in a travel rewards card and then some. Get your ticket to more with the new BMO VI Porter MasterCard and get up to $2,400 in value in your first 13 months. Terms and conditions apply visit Visit bmo.com slash VI Porter to learn more. Well, we're back and I'm gonna go first. I'm gonna talk about my very first best friend. She's still a dear friend of mine to this day. Her name is Karenca and her mom, Karina, and my mom were best friends in Indonesia.
They played tennis together and we were always at each other's houses. She has a big family with lots of older siblings and there was just always so much like hubbub in her house and I just loved it. And her mom, Karina, is Dutch and she introduced me to my favorite thing, which is mayonnaise with French fries. Oh, do you guys eat mayonnaise on your French fries?
Yeah, absolutely. I do ranch. Ranch, well, yeah, okay. We're pretty close. But she, anyway, isn't that just such a funny thing that I remember? Like she'd probably be like, Angela, I introduced you to so many foods,
but you remember mayonnaise and French fries. And Prince's dad is American. He was working overseas like my dad. And we were so tiny when we met. I was a toddler. Krenz is two years younger than me. She was just like a little thing in like diapers. And I don't have a memory of my childhood
that doesn't include her in that time. Wow. It was like she was just always part of my life because I met her when I was so little. Was she in Indonesia the whole time you were or did one of you, who moved away first? I moved away first. Okay.
Yeah. And we're so good friends to this day. We check in with each other a lot. We text each other. She is a librarian and she's been a librarian for over 20 years now at a middle school in Austin, Texas. She is so smart and so funny and just an amazing person.
And I'm so thankful that I have this childhood friend from such a special time in my life that I'm still in touch with, you know? Because when I started middle school, we moved around a lot and I really just hold close those friendships from back then. So shout out to Karenza. Well, a lot of the letters we got were from people whose first best friend is still their best friend.
Yeah. You know what? I want to read one from Alana D in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. She wrote in and said, My best friend Cassie and I met when we were three. She says, I remember the day. I was new to daycare and always sad when my mother left. Cassie started after me, and I remember her first day.
I knew then that it would all be okay. We've weathered so much all over the world. We've noticed how our conversations and how we care for one another have changed over the years. In our teens, we vetted each other's crushes. In our 20s, we nursed hangovers and traveling bugs. In our 30s and 40s, we took mom getaways and talked about our aches and pains as we were aging.
Most recently, Cassie came to Pittsburgh from Boston after I was diagnosed with breast cancer to be with me for the first whirlwind day of appointments. Her presence and us still being able to be us turned a potentially terrible day into something beautiful. She later came to help me recover after my bilateral mastectomy and spent days caring for me. Her family and boss okayed this time away, and I am grateful for how others also honor
and give space for our friendship. We are soulmates, and I know we can face anything that life brings together. Today was my last round of chemotherapy, and we are already planning our next adventure." Oh my gosh! That's so sweet. Yes. Alana, thank you so much for sharing that. What a wonderful friendship. Well, I love that letter.
I love their friendship. I actually pulled a letter from Carly B. in Newark, Texas. And it is again about a friendship that started when they were very young. Here's what Carly said. Carly said, My best friend London and I have been besties since we were seven years old.
We are now both in our thirties and living 800 miles apart, but are still bonded together as if we live right down the road from each other. My husband has my caller ID as light of my life, and he has London's caller ID as LightOfMyWife. That's really cute. We are incredibly different people with incredibly different opinions on literally everything,
but we are also the exact same person. Somehow it makes sense. We have this bit that's been running for so many years now, and it's hilarious every time it happens. I am a notoriously clumsy person and will drop food on myself at least once a day. If we're together, London will see that I've dropped food on myself
and immediately smudge a bite of her food on her clothing in solidarity with me. And we laugh until we can't breathe every time it happens. We talk all the time about the similarities between our friendship and y'all's. We love y'all and the podcast so much. Thanks for all you ladies do. I love that she smudges food on her.
I know, isn't that so fun? That is so fun. Well, Jenna, do you have a share about your very first best friend? I do, and you know, I lost touch with my very first best friend. I do. And, you know, I lost touch with my very first best friend. I don't know her anymore, but her name was Beth, and she lived up the street from me. We just lived in the same cul-de-sac.
Sure. And we were inseparable. And I loved going over to her house. Her mom would not let her eat sugar stuff, like sugar snacks or junk food, but she had this bowl of sugar-free candy lozenges. And I thought they were like the best thing on the planet. Isn't it funny the little things you remember? Mm-hmm. Yes.
But we would just, you know, we would ride bikes and do things in the neighborhood. And I loved her so much. And then her family moved. Oh. And I didn't get an address for her. It was sort of very sudden. Yes.
I mean, this is sort of part of our generation is that there weren't ways to stay in touch the same way there are now. And I think because my mom and Karence's mom were such good friends, that that was the bridge for us. Because we were little, we were young. I didn't, there was no social media, there was no cell phones, you know, you moved,
you got a new phone number, you know, all those things. Well, this was unfortunately like a common theme for me in that I would bond with someone and then their family would move. So Beth was my friend and we were, I don't know, like, I feel like we were like six, seven, eight years old. And then I just like didn't have a great friend for years. And then I became friends with this gal, Lauren,
who also lived a little further in my neighborhood, but who I met at school. And we became besties, like inseparable. I was so excited to have a friend again. And then she moved away. Oh no. But at least this time, we were older, we were in middle school when she moved away,
and I just was devastated. My mom recognized it. I did a trip where I flew by myself to see her in Boston, and she flew out to see me in Missouri once. But then again, like, kind of after that, we sort of lost touch when we were in high school. And so, you know, I've had kind of throughout my life, I've had these people who kind of like come and go. And now that I'm talking about it, I'm like,
wow, I wonder how that affected me. But I did have a very best friend in high school and then one in college and I sort of like get a best friend for each season of my life. But Anne, you're the one that stuck. I mean, I'm still friends with my high school and college best friends, but like, you know, yeah, I've also gone through periods of my life
where I didn't really have a best friend, like a true, like, tell you everything best friend. Yeah. I've had both. Well, I think we just met at our perfect time in our life for each other, you know? Yeah. And now we're older and we are in charge of, like,
all of our life, you know? Yeah. And we're not being moved by someone else and we can stay in touch. And I'm so proud of our friendship. And I tell this to people all the time that ask me about our friendship is that, you know, like any other relationship in your life,
to be a good friend, you have to put the time in. And even if distance happens or life happens, be like, all right, we have a phone date to catch up. And you just like, you work for the friendship. Well, both people, Alana and Carly, in both of their friendships, there was a move. Yeah. You know? Yeah.
Sam Cassie, do you have like, very first best friends that you remember from growing up? Yeah, my best friend's name was Amber. Do you have, like, very first best friends that you remember from growing up? Yeah, my best friend's name was Amber, and we would play in this canyon behind her house. And we were just totally, like, animal lovers and bonded over just being out in the woods. She meant a lot to me.
I love that. Are you still in touch with her? Kind of, like, on Instagram. But I moved to a different town? Kind of, like on Instagram. Sure. I moved to a different town when I was like 11. And when we came back, we were just totally different people at that point. Yeah. My childhood best friend, his name was Jared, is in Watertown, Wisconsin.
Used to ride our bikes around until the street lights came out, then it was time to come home. Sure. I lost touch of him. He went into the military around September 11th and isn't really online, but I should look him up. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, that's the thing too. I feel like it might be easier to find people now. I have a very dear friend, Kate, that was my middle school buddy that we stayed in touch for years. I went to Australia to see her. She came to the US to see me. And then one day, like, the card I sent her came back
and I, like, haven't been able to find her. So I love this idea of finding people that meant something to us and reconnecting. Well, we had another category of letters that we got from people. A lot of people sent in stories of how the office brought them together. Yeah.
Into their friendship. I really loved this one from Becca M. in Edmonds, Washington, who said, I, like the both of you, have the most amazing best friend. Her name is Lisa and we have been BFFs for 15 years. We met in college and pretty quickly became inseparable. She has been a supportive and loving person that I can always turn to. She even supported me in my own breast cancer scare
with love and laughter. We both have loved the office since day one. In college, we watched episodes together and totally fangirled over the romance of Jim and Pam, Angela and Dwight, and in my opinion, couples goals, Phyllis and Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration. And then she goes on to explain that for her bachelorette party,
her best friend threw her an office-themed girls' weekend. They got an Airbnb, and she decorated with a sign that said, it is your bachelorette party with half-blown-up balloons. They had fake tattoos that said that's what she said and also the face of prison Mike. And then she just said, "'I couldn't think of a better prompt to email about "'because I love the friendship between you two.
"'I always feel like I'm hearing a conversation "'between Lisa and myself when I tune in "'for the next installment of Office Ladies. "'And I hope everyone out there has their own Lisa "'because she's pretty effing amazing. "'Thanks for giving me an excuse to brag about my bestie. Aww, I love that. I love it when people have office-themed parties. It just delights me. They have office themed baby showers, bachelorette weddings, and of course birthdays. Yes. Isn't that so fun? It's so adorable.
Jenna and I gave Sam and Cassie each a birthday card that had the office ladies party planning committee on the front and we cut out little pictures of their faces and put them on Phyllis. We found a picture where they were both leaning the same way Phyllis is leaning. Anyway, it just tickles me and I love that the show still brings people together. Our next section is about best friendships in movies.
I looked up the top 15 best friendship movies, and Jenna, in the top 15. By the way, this made top 15, top 10 of several lists like this online. Okay. Is a movie that you and I went and saw in the theater together. on a BFF date. We did?
Yeah. Oh, oh wait, I think I know. It's the, it's the one with the pants. Yes. Sisterhood of the traveling pants. Yes, directed by our very own Ken Kloppis. We went to the theater to support the movie. I remember. Yeah. Oh, it was so good. And went to the theater to support the movie. I remember.
Oh, it was so good. And it's such a good BFF movie. I know. And can you believe that movie date of ours was 20 years ago? What? Yes. Lady, I looked it up. Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants is having its 20th year
anniversary this year. Oh my god. I know, it's crazy. It's also out on digital. Maybe we should watch it together again. Yes. 20 years of friendship. 20 years of friendship of those pants just traveling away.
今年是周年纪念日。天哪。我知道，太疯狂了。它也将推出数字版。也许我们应该再一起看一遍。是的。20年的友谊。那些裤子四处游历，带给我们的20年友谊。
Traveling the world. Lady, I have my blowout movie screen. We could do like an outdoor summer movie night and watch Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants. Oh, that would be so fun. We would have to take a picture together and send it to Ken. We would. Okay, so that one made almost all of the list,
游历世界。天哪，我有我的大电影屏幕。我们可以办一个户外夏日电影之夜，看《牛仔裤的夏天》。哦，那一定太有趣了。我们得一起拍张照片发给肯。必须的。好吧，这个几乎上了所有人的榜单，
but we were also curious to hear from everyone about what their best friendship movies are. I have two favorite best friendship movies. Okay. My second favorite that used to be my first favorite is Thelma and Louise. I love the friendship between these two women in this movie. That was number one on this top best friendship movie list.
但我们也很好奇大家心目中最棒的友谊电影是什么。我有两部最喜欢的友谊电影。好吧。我第二喜欢的电影曾经是我最喜欢的，那就是《末路狂花》。我喜欢这部电影中这两个女人之间的友谊。那是最佳友谊电影榜单上的第一名。
Well, I believe it because I remember seeing it when it came out and it was kind of the first time I had seen female friendship portrayed that way in a movie. And it was like very, it hit me. Like it definitely, like she has this speech at the end of the movie, Gina Davis's character, where she just says to Susan Sarandon, she's like, hey, I just want you to know, like,
嗯，我相信，因为我记得它刚上映时我看过，那可以说是电影中第一次这样刻画女性友谊。它非常深刻，触动了我。就像，它绝对是，就像她在电影结尾有段独白，吉娜·戴维斯饰演的角色，她对苏珊·萨兰登说，嘿，我只想让你知道，就像，
I can't go back to my old life. Like something has shifted in me. And Susan Sarandon is like, oh honey, I know. And it's just like, it gives me chills. It's just like this it gives me chills. It's just like this journey they go on and they are changed forever. And I felt like when I saw the movie,
我无法回到过去的生活了。我身上发生了某种变化。苏珊·萨兰登说，哦，亲爱的，我知道。那种感觉，让我起鸡皮疙瘩。就像是，这种感觉让我起鸡皮疙瘩。就像是他们经历的这段旅程，让他们彻底改变了。我觉得当我看到这部电影时，
it kind of changed something in me about women supporting women. It was just so beautiful. Yeah. And then my favorite best friendship movie though is Muriel's Wedding. Oh yeah. I love it so much.
它在女性支持女性这一点上，改变了我内心的一些东西。太美好了。是的。不过，我最喜欢的友谊电影是《穆丽尔的婚礼》。哦，是的。我太喜欢了。
And it's similar. It's similar. It's similar. It's just like a movie about best friends. And they're so great. And they have each other's back. And I just love it so much. Sam Cassidy, do you have a favorite best friendship movie? I've talked about this movie before, but Bottoms is just so good about, like,
而且很相似。很相似。很相似。这就像是一部关于挚友的电影。她们太棒了。她们互相支持。我太喜欢了。萨姆·卡西迪，你最喜欢的友谊电影是什么？我以前谈过这部电影，但《底线》真的很好，关于，
queer women and being gross and, you know, just stumbling through high school together, but coming together, I think, is just really beautiful. Their comedic comedy together in that movie is so infectious. Like, I could watch four hours of them. Same. I have to put that on my list.
酷儿女性，表现得有点粗俗，你知道的，一起磕磕绊绊地度过高中生活，但最终凝聚在一起，我觉得真的很美妙。他们在电影里的喜剧效果太有感染力了。我可以看他们演四个小时。一样。我得把那部加入我的榜单。
I haven't seen it. It's so good. OK. I would say either In Bruges, if you've seen that one. Oh, I love that. Colin Farrell and Brendan Gleeson. That's a great one. Or there's this movie, it's about four really good friends.
我没看过。太棒了。好吧。我会说是《杀手没有假期》，如果你看过那部的话。哦，我喜欢那个。科林·法瑞尔和布兰丹·格里森。那是一部好片子。或者还有这部电影，讲的是四个非常要好的朋友。
One of them has to return a ring and his three friends help him. It takes like nine hours, but it's really, really good. It's really, really good. And they have multiple goodbyes. Oh, they do. So many. If you love friends.
其中一个人必须去还戒指，他的三个朋友帮助他。大概花了九个小时，但真的非常非常棒。真的非常非常棒。而且他们进行了多次告别。哦，他们确实告别了。太多次了。如果你喜欢老友记的话。
Well, I'll have to check that out. Well, one of my favorite friendship movies, and I didn't think about that one, Sam, but that's right up there, but mine is actually Jane Austen's Pride and Prejudice. Okay. It just had its 20 year anniversary and it was re-released in the theaters
好吧，我得去看看。嗯，我最喜欢的友谊电影之一，萨姆，我之前没想到那部，但那部也很棒，不过我的是简·奥斯汀的《傲慢与偏见》。好的。它刚刚迎来20周年纪念，并在影院重新上映了
and I went with my friend. And it was so great. I have a friend that every year we meet and watch Pride and Prejudice. Her name is Tess. I just, I love this tradition that we have. But in the movie there is a friendship by love. It's between the characters Charlotte Lucas and Elizabeth Bennett. And, you know, they're these young girls and they've grown up together. Now they're having to figure out the next chapter of their life, marriage, all of that. And they can laugh and be silly, but then they can also get very real with one another. And I think that is true friendship when you just have to be real and be honest and you work through it and you get to the other side.
我和朋友一起去了。太棒了。我有一个朋友，我们每年都会聚在一起看《傲慢与偏见》。她叫苔丝。我真的很喜欢我们之间的这个传统。但在电影里，有一种因爱而生的友谊。发生在夏洛特·卢卡斯和伊丽莎白·班内特这两个角色之间。你知道，她们是这些年轻女孩，一起长大。现在她们必须弄清楚生活的下一章节，婚姻，诸如此类。她们可以大笑、傻笑，但随后也可以彼此坦诚相待。我认为这才是真正的友谊，当你必须真实、诚实，共同度过难关，迎来转机时。
And Charlotte has a speech that I love. She has just accepted the hand in marriage from Mr. Collins, who, you know, everyone thinks Mr. Collins is a bit of an idiot. And she goes to tell Elizabeth this, I saw Joe Wright interviewed about this speech and how it came about. And it's so interesting. I loved it so much.
夏洛特有一段我很喜欢的台词。她刚刚接受了柯林斯先生的求婚，你知道的，每个人都觉得柯林斯先生有点像个傻子。她去把这件事告诉伊丽莎白，我看到乔·赖特接受采访时谈到这段台词以及它是如何诞生的。太有趣了。我非常喜欢。
I want you to hear it. Oh, okay. Off with Charlotte Lucas. She's considered almost Like the ultimate millennial in an attitude because of her line. I'm 27 years old I've no money and no prospects. I'm already a burden to my parents And I'm frightened I've been told that and it reminds me of that scene being written. Deborah Marguk wrote the screenplay and did an amazing, amazing job. And then we asked Emma Thompson to help with a little bit of the dialogue.
我想让你听听。哦，好吧。关于夏洛特·卢卡斯。因为她的台词，她几乎被认为是最具千禧一代态度的人。我27岁了，没钱，也没有前景。我已经成了父母的累赘，而且我很害怕。我被告知过这些，这让我想起了被写下来的那一幕。黛博拉·莫盖克写了剧本，做得非常非常棒。然后我们请艾玛·汤普森帮忙处理了一小部分对话。
And I went around to her house, very nervous, with my little briefcase, and we walked up onto Hampstead Heath and she said, sit down, take out your notebook and take notes. So as she improvised scenes, I wrote them down and then her ending with, don't judge me, Lizzie, don't you dare judge me. Don't judge me, Lizzie. Don't you dare judge me. Wow. Isn't that brilliant? Emma Thompson improvised that speech. Anyway, I'm such a fan of hers, but I just loved that creative collaboration that Joe
我提着我的小公文包，非常紧张地走到她家，我们走到汉普斯特德希思，她说，坐下，拿出你的笔记本做笔记。于是当她即兴发挥场景时，我把它们记下来，最后她以“别评判我，莉兹，你休想评判我。别评判我，莉兹。你休想评判我”结尾。哇。是不是太精彩了？这段台词是艾玛·汤普森即兴发挥的。总之，我是她的超级粉丝，但我太喜欢乔带来的那种创意合作了。
Wright brought into this movie. But I loved that moment in Charlotte and Lizzie's friendship. And then they got through it, you know? And they were there for each other as their lives were changing. And so much of it was beyond their control and they were still there for each other as their lives were changing. And so much of it was beyond their control and they were still there for each other. Anyway, I just, I love that movie. I love that friendship.
赖特把这些融入了这部电影。但我喜欢夏洛特和莉兹友谊中的那一刻。然后她们度过了难关，你知道吗？当生活发生变化时，她们一直在彼此身边。很多事情都超出了她们的控制，但当生活发生变化时，她们依然在彼此身边。很多事情都超出了她们的控制，但她们依然在彼此身边。总之，我就是，我爱那部电影。我爱那种友谊。
I've never seen that movie. What? What? It's my favorite movie. I rewatch it all the time. Like if I can't sleep, I put on Pride and Prejudice. It's your edge. It's you're the edge.
我从来没看过那部电影。什么？什么？那是我最喜欢的电影。我一直重看。比如如果我睡不着，我就会播放《傲慢与偏见》。这是你的边缘。这是你的边缘。
It is. I can't believe you've never seen it. I've never seen it. I should see sleep, I put on Pride and Prejudice. It's your edge. It's you're the edge. It is. I can't believe you've never seen it. I've never seen it. I should see it, I guess. Yes. Yes, you should. In fact, I need it for our friendship. Here's my call to action. All right. To know me is to know how much I love this movie. Okay. I need you to see it.
确实是。真不敢相信你没看过。我从来没看过。我想我应该去看看。是的。是的，你该看看。事实上，为了我们的友谊我需要你去看。这是我的号召。好吧。了解我就知道我有多喜欢这部电影。好吧。我需要你去看。
Okay. Okay. Done. Okay. I will watch it this year. Oh, that would make me so happy. I need you to see it. Okay. Okay. Done. Okay. I will watch it this year. Oh, that would make me so happy. I can't wait. Okay. Don't watch it when you're distracted.
好吧。好吧。说定了。好吧。我今年会看的。哦，那会让我超级高兴。我需要你去看。好吧。好吧。说定了。好吧。我今年会看的。哦，那会让我超级高兴。我等不及了。好吧。分心的时候别看。
Put some alone time there. Okay. So not while like on a lunch break, like I did with Lord of the Rings and you guys all gave me trouble for it. I will be wounded. Okay. I will not.
给自己留点独处的时间。好吧。所以不要像吃午餐休息时那样，就像我看《指环王》时你们都拿我取笑那样。我会受伤的。好吧，我不会的。
Let's like when we were gonna watch the edge, you're like, and you can't make fun of it. It means too much to me. I did. Okay, I will not. That's like when we were going to watch the edge, you're like, and you can't make fun of it. It means too much to me. I did. Okay. I said that. All right. Okay. Deal. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, I did do a deep dive on friendship.
就像我们要看边缘的时候，你总是说，你不能取笑它。它对我有很重要的意义。我确实这么做了。好吧，我不会的。就像我们要去看边缘的时候，你总是说，你不能取笑它。它对我有很重要的意义。我做了。好吧。我这么说过的。好吧。好吧。成交。听着，我们为什么不休息一下？然后当我们回来时，我确实对友谊做了深入研究。
There's people have studied it. Oh. And I found some stuff that was interesting to me. Fantastic. I'll share it. All right. ["Dreams of a New World"] Oh, this is it. The day you finally ask for that big promotion. You're in front of your mirror with your Starbucks coffee.
有人研究过它。哦。我发现了一些让我感兴趣的东西。太棒了。我会分享的。[《新世界的梦想》]哦，就是这个。你终于要求大幅加薪的那一天。你正对着镜子，手里拿着星巴克咖啡。
Be confident, assertive, remember eye contact, but also remember to blink. Smile, but not too much, that's weird. What if you aren't any good at your job? What if they demote you instead? Okay, don't be silly. You're smart, you're driven, you're gonna be late if you keep talking to the mirror.
要自信、坚定，记住要有眼神交流，但也别忘了眨眼。微笑，但不要笑得太过分，那样很奇怪。万一你工作干得不好怎么办？万一他们反而把你降职了呢？好吧，别傻了。你很聪明，很有进取心，如果你继续对着镜子说话，就要迟到了。
This promotion is yours. Go get them. Starbucks, it's never just coffee. When does fast grocery delivery through Instacart matter most? When your famous grainy mustard potato salad isn't so famous without the grainy mustard. When the barbecue's lit, but there's nothing to grill. When the in-laws decide that, actually, they will stay for dinner.
这个促销是给你的。去拿下他们吧。星巴克，从来不只是咖啡。什么时候通过Instacart享受快速杂货配送最重要？当你著名的粗粒芥末土豆沙拉没有了粗粒芥末就不那么著名的时候。当烧烤开炉了，却没有什么可烤的时候。当公婆决定，实际上，他们要留下来吃晚饭的时候。
Instacart has all your groceries covered this summer, so download the app and get delivery in as fast as 60 minutes. Plus enjoy zero dollar delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees exclusions and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Well, we're back and I'm very excited for your friendship deep dive. Well, lady, I love anecdotes.
这个夏天，Instacart帮你搞定所有日常杂货，现在就下载应用，享受最快60分钟送达服务。此外，前三单还可享受零元配送服务。服务费、排除条款和相关规定适用。Instacart，超值送达的杂货。好了，我们回来了，我非常期待你们的友谊深度剖析。好吧，女士，我喜欢轶事。
I love studies. I love research projects. I love studies. I love research projects. This is true. And I was Googling, and I found that in 2011, Snapchat did a research project called the Friendship Report. And their goal was to examine the state and nature of friendships around the world. Okay. So I read the world. Okay.
我喜欢研究。我喜欢研究项目。我喜欢研究。我喜欢研究项目。这是真的。我当时在用谷歌搜索，发现2011年Snapchat做了一个名为《友谊报告》的研究项目。他们的目标是审视世界各地友谊的现状和本质。好的。所以我读了全世界。好的。
So I read the report. It was very lengthy. I was gonna say, how long is it? It's very long. And you read the whole thing? Yeah, wow. I mean, I love this for my free time. I love to read a lengthy research report.
所以我读了这份报告。它非常长。我是说，它有多长？非常长。你把整篇都读完了？是啊，哇。我的意思是，我喜欢在空闲时间做这事。我喜欢阅读冗长的研究报告。
That just gives me joy. And this is probably why I'm Jan. I'll just mention a few of the things that really struck me in reading the report. It showed how people were really good at making friends when they were younger. However, in our 30s and 40s, friendships became both harder to make
这能带给我快乐。这大概就是为什么我是珍。我只提几件在阅读报告时真正震撼我的事。它显示了人们在年轻时是多么擅长交朋友。然而，在我们30多和40多岁时，友谊变得既难以建立
and harder to maintain. And then they listed the most common stressors to a friendship. These are the most common reasons why a friendship ended. Okay. And most commonly in your 30s and 40s. Number one was a new love. Like one of the friends got a new love. Right. Number two was parenthood. Someone became a parent. Number three was employment. So something having to do with getting busy at work or changing jobs or something. Number four was loss of a loved one. And number five was relocation. In fact, I actually read these in no particular order because relocation was the top reason people lost touch
又难以维持。然后他们列出了友谊中最常见的压力源。这些是友谊结束最常见的原因。好的。最常见于30多岁和40多岁的时候。第一位是新恋情。比如其中一个朋友有了新恋情。对。第二位是为人父母。有人成为了父母。第三位是工作。也就是工作变得忙碌、换工作或类似的事情。第四位是失去亲人。第五位是搬迁。事实上，我读这些时并没有按特定顺序，因为搬迁是人们失去联系的头号原因
with a friend, physical distance. I was looking at that list and I have lost a friend for all five of those reasons. You know, I shared that my first two best friends I lost over relocation. Yes, but yeah, all those things. Yeah. But then I also made friends in those categories.
与朋友的物理距离。我看着那个名单，因为这五种原因我都失去过朋友。你知道的，我分享过，我的前两个最好朋友就是因为搬迁而失去的。是的，但，所有这些事。是的。但后来我也在这些类别里交到了朋友。
So like when I fell in love with Lee, he brought new friendships into my life. Right. And when I became a parent, I became friends with new people from that category. Right. You know? So, yeah, kind of interesting.
所以，比如当我爱上李时，他给我的生活带来了新的友谊。对。当我成为父母时，我从那个类别中结识了新朋友。对。你知道吗？所以，是的，挺有意思的。
I think it's right on. I mean, I can check a few of those boxes as well. Well, they also in this report had suggestions for how to make friends. Okay. And this one really stood out to me. Their first piece of advice for making new friends is to assume people like you. Just assume. Can that be a little dangerous? Like isn't that a slippery slope? Like you're like yeah
我觉得完全正确。我的意思是，我也可以勾选其中几项。嗯，这份报告里也对如何交朋友提出了建议。好的。而这个特别让我印象深刻。他们关于结交新朋友的第一条建议是假设别人喜欢你。就假设。这会不会有点危险？这难道不是一条滑坡效应吗？就像你会想，是的
they like me. They're like no, no. Well here's what they said. Researchers found that when people were told that they would be accepted into a group, even when it wasn't true, like they would take a group of people who were already associated with themselves and introduce a new person, and they would tell this person, hey, this group is excited to meet you.
他们喜欢我。他们说，不，不。嗯，他们是这么说的：研究人员发现，当人们被告知他们会被一个群体接受时，即使这不是真的，比如他们会把一群本已有关联的人聚在一起，并引入一个新成员，他们会告诉这个人，嘿，这个群体很高兴能见到你。
They've already accepted you as their friend. And then they did it where they didn't tell that person that. And so you entered the group with different confidence. Yes. And confidence, people are attracted to confidence. Well, what they said was the people who were told that they would be accepted,
他们已经接受你作为他们的朋友了。然后他们在不告诉那个人的情况下也做了一次。所以你带着不同的自信进入了这个群体。是的。而自信，人们会被自信吸引。嗯，他们所说的是，那些被告知他们会被接受的人，
those people let their guard down more, they shared more, they disagreed less and were just overall more positive. Hmm. Researchers also discovered something called the liking gap. What is the liking gap? Okay. When strangers interact- You're smiling. You're so tickled.
这些人更加卸下了防备，分享了更多，反对的声音更少，总体上更加积极。嗯。研究人员还发现了一种叫做“喜爱差距”的东西。什么是喜爱差距？好的。当陌生人互动时——你在笑。你太高兴了。
I love anecdotes, you guys. You can't wait to tell me what the liking gap is. I live for this shit. You also look really cute today. Hey, thanks. I mean, Sam and I were talking about it. We love your hair. It's got a little swoop. It's longer. It looks really nice today.
我喜欢轶事，你们。你们迫不及待地想告诉我什么是喜爱差距了。我就是为了这个活着的。你今天看起来也很可爱。嘿，谢谢。我是说，萨姆和我一直在讨论这个。我们喜欢你的头发。有点向内卷。更长了。今天看起来真不错。
Right? It's starting to finally turn. And then for a while, it was just growing up and out. And now it is starting to bend. It's starting to lay down a little. And then I love your top and your pants. Thank you so much. Anyway, whatever. Head to toe cute outfit.
对吧？它终于开始定型了。然后有一段时间，它只是向上和向外长。现在它开始弯曲了。开始有点服帖了。然后我喜欢你的上衣和裤子。非常感谢。不管怎样，总之是一身可爱的造型。
Back to the liking gap. Oh, my goodness. Well. Back to the liking gap. Oh, my goodness. Well, here's the liking gap. When strangers interacted with each other, they were asked later to estimate how liked they thought they were by the other person, and people routinely underestimate their likability. Like, their interpretation of if the other person liked them
回到喜爱差距。哦，天哪。嗯。回到喜爱差距。哦，天哪。嗯，这就是喜爱差距：当陌生人彼此互动时，他们后来被要求估计他们认为对方有多喜欢自己，而人们通常会低估自己的受欢迎程度。就像，他们对对方是否喜欢自己的解读
was not in sync with the reality that the person did like them. So they were using that as an example to say, like, you can assume that people will like you. Like, you are good enough, you are likable. Carry that into the room with you, everybody. Okay. I don't know. I thought that could be helpful with you, everybody. Okay. I don't know. I thought that could be helpful. No, I think it is helpful. All right, here was their other suggestion
与对方实际上确实喜欢他们的现实并不一致。所以他们用这个作为一个例子来说明，你可以假设别人会喜欢你。比如，你足够好，你很讨人喜欢。把这一点带入房间里，大家。好吧。我不知道。我以为这会对大家有帮助。好吧。我不知道。我以为这会有帮助。不，我觉得确实有帮助。好吧，这是他们的另一个建议
for making friends. I am on board with this. Okay, good. Okay, good. Here's their other suggestion for making friends, which is don't wait for friendships to happen organically. Studies show that friendships take effort and initiative. And one of the suggestions was, you know, in the same way that when you're looking for love,
关于如何交朋友。我赞同这个。太好了。好的，太好了。这是他们关于交朋友的另一个建议，那就是不要等待友谊自然而然地发生。研究表明，友谊需要付出努力和主动。其中一个建议是，你知道的，就像你在寻找真爱时，
you'll kind of do one of the like online matching things that like actually finding a friend online is a good place to like take initiative. And you know, find someone who you might want to be friends with. Yes, and we actually got a letter from Sani Wye And, you know, find someone who you might want to be friends with. Who you connect with. Yes, and we actually got a letter from Sani Wye in sunny Finland who met her friend that way, who said,
你会做那种类似在线匹配的事情，其实在网上找朋友也是一个采取主动的好地方。而且你知道的，找一个你可能想和她交朋友的人。是的，我们实际上收到了一封来自萨尼·怀的信，以及，你知道的，找一个你可能想和她交朋友的人。你与她有连接的人。是的，我们实际上收到了一封来自阳光灿烂的芬兰的萨尼·怀的信，她就是通过这种方式结识了她的朋友，她说，
So basically, I met my best friend online. I think it was somewhere in the early 2010s. I'm Finnish and she's Hungarian. English isn't even our first language and yet we still somehow became really close, really fast. Our long-distance friendship is very cool and we have even met twice, once in Hungary and once in Finland. Even if we won't see each other in years, we still connect. We FaceTime, text and call, send each other silly reels and laugh together through the phone. I know it's not an ideal
所以基本上，我是在网上认识我最好的朋友的。我想大概是在2010年代初。我是芬兰人，她是匈牙利人。英语甚至都不是我们的第一语言，然而我们不知怎么地还是很快变得非常亲密。我们的异地友谊非常酷，我们甚至见过两次面，一次在匈牙利，一次在芬兰。即使我们好几年不见面，我们依然保持联系。我们用FaceTime、发短信和打电话，互相发送搞笑的短视频，并在电话里一起大笑。我知道这不是理想的
friendship, but it's special for both of us. We always have a friend in our pocket." Well, I love that. That is something we did not have growing up. We did not have this online option. But you know, as you were saying all of that, Jenna, it made me think of a family story that my sister tells. I hadn't thought about it in a long time, but as you were reading that, I was visiting my sister in the summer.
友谊，但对我们俩来说都很特别。我们的口袋里随时都有一个朋友。”嗯，我很喜欢这样。这是我们成长过程中没有的。我们当时没有这种在线的选择。但是你知道的，正当你讲这一切的时候，珍，这让我想起了一个我姐姐讲的家族故事。我很长时间没想起它了，但当你读到那段时，我夏天正在拜访我姐姐。
You know, my sister's much older than me and she was married and my parents had some work travel and so I went and stayed with her for two or three weeks one summer. And I was, I don't know, maybe like 13 years old. Anyway, I got bored really quickly with just my sister and her husband. And, you know, I would just sit around. I was real bored. And so my sister was like, well, there had been this girl. Every day we'd see her ride her bike down the street. And my sister was like, well, why don't you make friends with her?
你知道的，我姐姐比我大很多，她已经结婚了，我父母有一些工作上的旅行，所以我去和她一起住了两三个星期，就在某个夏天。那时我，不知道，大概13岁吧。总之，光是和我姐姐姐夫在一起，我很快就觉得无聊了。而且，你知道的，我就会坐在那里。我真的很无聊。所以我姐姐就说，嗯，有这么个女孩。我们每天都看到她骑自行车顺着街道过去。我姐姐就说，嗯，你为什么不和她交朋友呢？
You know? And I finally was like just bored enough that I had the courage. And I walked outside one day and my sister said, as she rode her bike by, I stuck my foot out in front of her bike and I said, hey, you wanna be friends? Did it work? She was like, okay.
你知道吗？我最后终于无聊到有了勇气。有一天我走到外面，我姐姐说，当她骑自行车经过时，我把脚伸到她的自行车前面，我说，嘿，你想交个朋友吗？管用吗？她说，好吧。
And then I borrowed a bike and we'd go ride bikes together for like a few weeks, we hung out. But it is kind of funny to me, I hadn't thought about that in a long time. Well, you did it, you took some initiative. You did not wait for that. That is definitely not a friendship that started organically. No. That was initiative-based. I blocked her bike with my body. Here was their third suggestion for how to make friend. Pursue a group hobby. Oh, yeah.
然后我借了一辆自行车，我们一起骑了好几个星期的自行车，我们一起闲逛。但对我来说这有点搞笑，我已经很久没有想起那个了。嗯，你做到了，你采取了一些主动。你没有干等。这绝对不是一段自然开始的友谊。没有。那是基于主动的。我用身体挡住了她的自行车。这是他们关于如何交朋友的第三个建议。追求一个集体爱好。哦，是的。
This is 100% how I made friends when I first came to Los Angeles. 100%. Here are some suggestions. Take a yoga class. Libraries have book clubs. Pickleball. Join a pickup hockey game. Lee has made so many friends.
这绝对是我刚来洛杉矶时交朋友的方法。百分之百。这里有一些建议。上瑜伽课。图书馆有读书俱乐部。匹克球。参加一场临时组局的冰球比赛。莉（Lee）交了好多朋友。
He plays pickup hockey. He used to play soccer. He was on like a softball team. Like sports is a great. Sports is great. Right? He's pick up hockey, he used to play soccer, he was on like a softball team. Like sports is a great. Sports is great. Right? Is improv, like improv class on there?
他会打临时冰球。他以前踢过足球。他参加过类似垒球队的组织。体育运动真的是个好东西。体育运动太棒了。对吧？他会打临时冰球，他以前踢过足球，他参加过类似垒球队的组织。体育运动真的是个好东西。体育运动太棒了。对吧？即兴表演呢，比如即兴表演课在不在里面？
It wasn't, but it could be. Yeah, take an improv class. You'll meet lots of people from all over. You will. What? Why are you looking at me like that? Some people in improv classes are weird. That's how I made all of my friends.
不在，但也可以有。对，去上即兴表演课。你会遇到来自各行各业的很多人。真的会的。什么？你为什么那样看着我？有些人上即兴表演课时挺怪的。我所有的朋友都是这么交到的。
I know, but you will meet a Michael Scott in your improv class. You will, and I have collected a random assortment of people in my life. It's true. Okay, sorry, improv classes. They are a good place to meet people. They are.
我知道，但你在即兴表演课上会遇到一个迈克尔·斯科特。真的会的，而且我在生活中结识了各种各样形形色色的人。确实如此。好吧，抱歉，即兴表演课。它们确实是结识新朋友的好地方。的确是。
Sam, I wanted to throw it over to you because I know that you have been on a journey this past year. It is a sobriety journey, and you've shared about this in other places on your Instagram and a little bit here on Office Ladies. But part of that journey has involved you having to make new friendships and connections.
萨姆，我想把话题交给你，因为我知道你过去这一年经历了一段心路历程。这是一段戒酒之旅，你已经在你的Instagram以及《办公室女士》（Office Ladies）节目的其他地方分享过这一点了。但这段旅程的一部分，也包括你不得不结交新的友谊和人脉。
It has, yes. Can you share a little bit about what that has meant for you? I would love to. Yeah, making new friends this year has been weird and difficult. Making friends over 40 is difficult in general. And I just way overestimated how simple it would be. But it has been new this year, taking classes,
确实如此，是的。你能分享一下这对你意味着什么吗？我很乐意。是的，今年结交新朋友的感觉很奇妙也很艰难。总的来说，年过四十再交朋友本来就很困难。而且我把事情想得太简单了，远远高估了它的容易程度。但今年确实有了新的尝试，比如上课，
taking so many classes. I took a fencing class this Sunday, and cello lessons, and sign language classes, and kickball classes, and bowling classes. So yeah, this year has just been an interesting experiment in meeting new people, meeting new sober people. Have any of those things that you've joined in your effort to connect with new sober people.
上了超级多的课。我这个星期天去上了一节击剑课，还有大提琴课、手语课、踢球课和保龄球课。所以，是的，今年只是在结识新朋友、结识戒酒的新朋友方面做了一个有趣的实验。为了结识新的戒酒朋友，你加入的这些活动里，
Has it worked? Yeah, it has. Yeah, I've made a bunch of new friends that I wouldn't have met any other places outside of 12 step programs. It's been really, really nice. That's so great. Yeah. You know, my sister years ago, she'd gone through a divorce and moved and was really
有管用的吗？对，管用的。是的，我结交了一帮新朋友，如果不是通过十二步戒酒项目，我在其他任何地方都遇不到他们。这真的、真的很美好。太棒了。是的。你知道吗，我姐姐多年前经历过离婚并搬了家，真的是
kind of starting over. And she had a student that year that she took it upon herself to learn sign language, to help communicate with her students' parents. And she just started taking more and more classes. And she found a community that she absolutely adored. And she's dear friends with now. And even this week, she's here to visit me from Texas.
从头开始。那年她有一个学生，她主动去学习手语，为了能和学生的家长沟通。于是她开始去上越来越多的课。她找到了一个她极其喜爱的社群。现在他们成了挚友。甚至就在本周，她还从得克萨斯州来这里看望我。
And she's going to meet up with two of her friends she met. Oh, I love that. In this online sign language class. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, that's awesome. So I just love that, Sam. I think that is showing great initiative about how do I meet people and have a shared interest
她打算和她在网上手语课上认识的两个朋友见个面。哦，我太喜欢这个了。对，对。太棒了。所以我真的很喜欢这样，萨姆。我觉得这表现出了极大的积极性，关于如何在这个我正经历的新旅程中结识朋友并找到共同的兴趣。
on this new journey that I'm on. Thank you. It's been really, really weird and very lonely, but in a good way. I mean, how many times have you had to step into a room of strangers this last year? I mean, that is not easy to do. About once a week for this last year.
谢谢。这真的、真的很诡异，也非常孤独，但从好的方面来说是这样的。我是说，过去这一年你得多少次走进一个全都是陌生人的房间啊？我的意思是，这可真不是件容易的事。过去这一年里大约每周一次。
Oh, Sam. That is courage. And are you assuming people like you? Oh, okay, here's the thing. No, and I made a mental note when you came across that thing earlier. I'm just not wired that way naturally. I'm naturally hardwired to not like myself.
哦，萨姆。这太需要勇气了。而且你在默认别人会喜欢你吗？哦，好吧，事情是这样的。没有，你刚才提到那个事的时候，我在心里默默记下了。我天生就不是那种思维方式的人。我天生就倾向于不喜欢自己。
It's like a thing I'm dealing with in therapy and this, all this stuff. So that, I like threw my hands up when you got to that point, like as if it's just a decision to like yourself that is crazy to me. Well, Sam, I can relate. I mean, this is the root of all of my social anxiety
这是我在心理治疗中正在处理的一个问题，诸如此类的事情。所以当你们聊到那个观点时，我双手一摊，就好像喜欢自己只是一个决定一样，这对我来说太疯狂了。好吧，萨姆，我能感同身受。我是说，我所有的社交焦虑的根源，
is my incredibly loud self-critic. Yeah. And so that's why that stood out to me, this idea that I could just assume people will like me. I'm like, what does that feel like? I will say all 52 times that I've walked into a room of new people this year, I've absolutely had that emotional hangover,
就是我那个声音奇响无比的内心批判者。对。所以这就是为什么那个观点对我触动很深，那种“我可以直接假设别人会喜欢我”的想法。我想：那种感觉是什么样的？我得说，今年我走进陌生人房间的所有52次经历中，在回家的路上，绝对都有过那种所谓的宿醉情绪，
they call it, on the way home, where you're going through stuff you said and you're like, oh, why did I say this? No one likes you. Everything was fine, by the way, but it's just replaying the night. Well, Sam, you know that I know exactly what you're talking about.
就是你会在脑海里回顾自己说过的话，然后想：“天哪，我为什么要说这个？没人会喜欢你。”顺便说一句，其实一切都很好，但这只是在反复回放当晚的情景。好吧，萨姆，你知道我完全明白你在说什麽。
I spiral often. So I definitely, definitely have had that experience. And you know what? Just thank you so much for sharing all that, because friendship is something that does elude people at various times in their life. It is not effortless and it's not easy. So thank you for sharing.
我经常陷入思维死胡同。所以我绝对、绝对有过那种经历。你知道吗？非常感谢你分享这一切，因为友谊确实是人在生命中不同阶段会难以企及的东西。它不是毫不费力的，也绝非轻而易举。所以谢谢你的分享。
Thank you for having me. Yeah. Well, Angela, this whole episode got me reflecting on the circumstances that led to our friendship. If I had to like name the main thing that led to our friendship, I'm talking like origin, moment. Yes. I would have to say it was as simple as location proximity.
谢谢你们邀请我。好的，安吉拉，这一整集节目都让我回想起促成我们友谊的环境。如果我必须说出促成我们友谊的最主要因素，我是指最初的契机。是的。我不得不说，其实就这么简单，因为地理位置挨得很近。
I was going to say proximity. We worked at the same place, but not just that. Our desks were right next to each other. Our desks backed each other up. You were the closest lady, gal, next to each other. Our desks backed each other up. You were the closest lady, gal next to me. Yep. And we got a fan letter that reminded me of the two of us. It is from Kristen R. in Buffalo, New York,
我本来想说是因为离得近。我们在同一个地方上班，但不仅如此。我们的办公桌紧挨着彼此。我们的办公桌背靠背。你是离我最近的那位女士、姑娘。我们的办公桌背靠背。你是离我最近的那位女士、姑娘。没错。而且我们收到了一封粉丝来信，让我想起了我们俩。信来自纽约州水牛城的克里斯汀·R（Kristen R.），
who said, my best friend, Corey, and I met in the office. We had just finished college and she just had a baby, but we were two peas in a pod from day one. We were assigned desks that connected. Hey! And boy, did that come in handy. We used a headphone jack splitter to listen to music and podcasts together.
她说：“我和我最好的朋友科里（Corey）在办公室认识。我们刚大学毕业，她刚生了孩子，但从第一天起我们就形影不离。我们被安排在相连的办公桌。嘿！这可真派上大用场了。我们用耳机分线器一起听音乐和播客。
One year for Halloween, we dressed as the SNL ladies from the delicious dish. She left the office after a few years to raise her kids, but I still work for the company. Almost 14 years later, I've had six promotions. She's had three more kids. They call me Auntie. We're practically family,
有一年的万圣节，我们打扮成《美味佳肴》（Delicious Dish）里的周六夜现场（SNL）女士。几年后她为了带孩子离开了办公室，但我还在公司工作。将近14年过去了，我升职了六次。她又生了三个孩子。他们叫我阿姨。我们简直就像一家人一样，
and I'm forever grateful for our office." I love that. You know, I'm so thankful for the proximity of our desk, but also it was the first time we talked. There was just a familiarity about you. I just felt an instant comfort around you. You felt like home to me. You felt like here I was in the middle of Hollywood on a TV set, but you felt like a
我永远对我们的办公室情谊心怀感激。”我太喜欢这个了。你知道的，我非常感激我们办公桌离得这么近，但这也是我们第一次说话时的感觉。你身上有一种让人感到熟悉的气息。我对你立刻有一种由衷的舒适感。你让我觉得就像家一样。你让我觉得我仿佛身处好莱坞中间的一个片场里，但你却像是一个
friend I would make back home. And it was just really simple day-to-day life things that we talked about, you know? And those are the things and the moments that get you through life. You know, big things come and go and swirl around you. But it's the day-to-day, I feel like, that builds lasting friendships. And I went to my office early days journal, and I have a little entry and it's nothing flashy. It's just a simple entry. But I think it says everything about who we were then
我在老家会结交的朋友。我们聊的都是非常简单的日常生活琐事，你知道吗？正是这些事情和时刻陪你度过人生。你知道，大事来来去去，在你身边风风雨雨。但我觉得，正是日常生活构建了持久的友谊。我翻看了我早期办公室日记，里面有一条短小的记录，没什么浮夸的。只是一条简单的记录。但我认为它说明了一切，关于当时的我们，
and why I love it so much. Are you ready? Yes. Okay. Putting on my glasses. Back from lunch, Jenna and I ate in her trailer. It's my favorite. She brought arm weights to keep in her trailer.
以及为什么我如此深爱那段时光。准备好了吗？是的。好的。戴上我的眼镜。“午休回来，詹娜和我一起在她的拖车里吃东西。这是我的最爱。她带了手臂哑铃放在拖车里。
And after we ate, she did some arm exercises while I talked. I showed her the push-up thing I do on the counter. You know what I'm talking about. I do, of course. It's this like lame push-up I do just leaning on a counter. Then I go in to say, maybe I'll get some weights too. Sitting at my desk now, it's so cold on set. I scooch my seat as far under my desk as it can go
吃完饭后，我一边说话，她一边做一些手臂锻炼。我向她展示了我在柜台上做的俯卧撑动作。你知道我在说什么。我当然知道。就是那种我靠在柜台上做的很逊的俯卧撑。接着我说，‘也许我也该买点哑铃。’现在坐在办公桌前，片场好冷。我把椅子尽量往办公桌底下挪，
so the camera won't see my Uggs. Jenna likes my hair today. It's a half up, half down look. I wanted to come see the two hydrangeas I planted in my backyard. They are finally starting to bloom. I had them in pots and waited to plant them until I figured out which part of the yard
这样镜头就拍不到我的UGG雪地靴了。詹娜今天很喜欢我的头发。是一个半扎半放的发型。我想去看看我后院里种的两株绣球花。它们终于开始开花了。我以前把它们种在花盆里，一直等到确定院子里哪个地方
got the most shade. It's riveting stuff here, guys. I go on to say, "'Jenna and I don't work tomorrow, so we are going to the Beverly Center to shop and have lunch in the food court.' Wow! That's a shopping mall here.
阴凉最多时，才把它们移栽到地里。这里的事情真是扣人心弦啊，各位。”我接着写道：“‘詹娜和我明天不上班，所以我们要去贝弗利中心（Beverly Center）购物，并在美食广场吃午饭。’哇！那是这里的一个购物中心。
Yes. I go on and say, "'I'm so excited. We never get days off together during the week. Parking is annoying, so I said we should carpool. Yay. All righty. A better run.
是的。我接着写道：‘我太兴奋了。我们平时从来没有一起在工作日放过假。停车太烦人了，所以我说我们应该拼车。耶。好吧。我得赶紧走了。’
I love this journal entry. Isn't it just so simple? But that is it, lady. Like you saying, will you come see my hydrangea that I planted, which by the way I remember doing, is why we're friends, because I couldn't wait to see them. I was like, yes, I'd love to come see those.
我太喜欢这篇日记了。是不是就这么简单？但这就是全部了，女士。就像你说的那样：‘你会来看我种的绣球花吗？’顺便一提，我记得当时的情形，这就是为什么我们能成为朋友，因为我迫不及待地想去看它们。我当时就想：‘太好了，我很乐意去看那些花。’
And I just remember just us being in your trailer and our lunch is there. It's no surprise to me that I wrote, it's my favorite thing, because it's really, being on set was so fun and acting on the office was so fun. But where I felt most like me was on our lunches
而且我还记得我们待在你的拖车里、在那里吃午饭的情景。我写下‘这是我最喜欢的事’一点也不让我意外，因为在片场真的很开心，在《办公室》里演戏也真的好开心。但我最觉得像我自己的地方，是在我们拖车里的午餐时间，
in your trailer, where we just got to chit chat. Well, I remember a big swing that I took in our friendship and I was so nervous. I was like sweaty palms. My heart was like beating out of my chest. I literally don't know what you're about to say. Okay, I had been at the mall and I had gone by Claire's and I saw that cheesy, like best friend necklace
在那儿我们只是天南海北地闲聊。嗯，我记得在我们的友谊中，我曾迈出过很大的一步，当时我紧张极了。我手心直冒汗。我的心跳得像要蹦出胸膛一样。我简直不知道你接下来要说什么。好吧，我当时去商场逛过，路过了克莱尔饰品店（Claire's），我看到了那种俗气的、类似最好朋友的项链，
where like one side says B-Fry and the other side says St. Enns, but if you put them together, it says best friends. And I just had this instinct. I was like, oh my gosh, I'm gonna get that for me and Angela. And then I realized we had never called each other best friends, but I knew you were my best friend. I did not have another best friend.
就是一边写着B-Fry，另一边写着St. Enns，但如果你把它们拼在一起，就写着“最好朋友”（best friends）。我当时就有一种直觉。我心里想：‘天哪，我要买这个给我和安吉拉。’然后我意识到我们以前从来没有称呼对方为最好朋友，但我知道你就是我的最好朋友。我当时没有别的最好朋友。
I didn't even have another close friend at the time. And I remember standing in that Claire's and being like, do I buy it? What if, what if I give it to her? And she's like, oh, thanks. Like, or am I, is it too much too soon? But I bought it and I gave it to you. And you were like, I love it, I love it, BFFs.
那时候我甚至连另一个知心朋友都没有。我记得自己站在那家克莱尔饰品店里纠结：‘我要买吗？万一……万一我把它送给她，而她说：“哦，谢谢”呢？或者我是不是表现得太急、太刻意了？’但我还是买下了它，并把它送给了你。你当时说：‘我好喜欢，我好喜欢，BFFs（永远的最好朋友）。’
And it was like, it was a little bit like saying, I love you for the first time in a relationship. And I was like, yes, we're besties. We're besties. You know I loved it. I had just made us matching sweatshirts with our character names on them. Yes.
这就有点像恋爱中第一次说“我爱你”的感觉。我当时就想：‘耶，我们是最好闺蜜。我们是最好闺蜜。’你知道我很喜欢它。我当时刚给我们做了一对印有我们角色名字的配套运动衫。没错。
Well, everyone, thank you so much for joining us in this celebration of friendship and best friends day. This was so wonderful. I love that our show brings people together. I love that our job brought us together. And I love hearing people's friendship stories. Actually, sorry, before we go, I brought in something from my journal today. If that's all right. What. What? Yeah. Wait, Sam. Sorry, do we have time? We do. This is a curveball. I'll try and
好了，各位，非常感谢大家加入我们，一起庆祝友谊和最好朋友日。这真是太美妙了。我喜欢我们的节目将人们聚在一起。我喜欢我们的工作将我们聚在一起。我也喜欢听大家的友谊故事。其实，抱歉，在我们离开之前，我今天从我的日记里带了一点东西过来。如果可以的话。什么。什么。等等，萨姆。抱歉，我们还有时间吗？有的。这真是一个意料之外的转折。我会尽量
keep this short. There's just something I wanted to express to the three of you on air. In case something happens to me, I'd like these thoughts permanently recorded forever in clear posterity. Sam, your brain is hilarious. It's gonna start rough, but it'll perk up by the end, I promise. Okay. This last year was a doozy for me. I got sober shortly after being let go from SiriusXM. Although it never affected my work in studio, the last decade of my life has been fairly controlled by drugs and alcohol behind the scenes. When I was let go from SiriusXM, I realized that the unlimited time and severance package
长话短说。我只是有些话想在节目中对你们三个人表达。万一我出了什么事，我希望这些想法能永远、清晰地永久记录在案，留作后代纪念。萨姆，你的脑回路太搞笑了。开头可能会比较艰难，但我保证最后会好起来的。好吧。过去这一年对我的打击可真不小。我在被SiriusXM解雇后不久就戒酒了。虽然这从未影响我在录音室的工作，但在幕后，我过去十年的生活在很大程度上一直被毒品和酒精所控制。当我被SiriusXM解雇时，我意识到无限的空闲时间和离职补偿金，
would most assuredly result in an overdose if I didn't get help. And I did. I joined a 12-step program, got a sponsor, and dove in with full conviction. But as I'm learning is the case with most addicts, the real struggle is dealing with what lies underneath. The character defects and trauma that I needed in numb with drugs and alcohol.
如果我不寻求帮助，几乎肯定会导致药物过量。而我确实寻求了帮助。我参加了一个十二步戒酒项目，找了一个保荐人（sponsor），并带着全副信念一头扎了进去。但正如我逐渐了解到的情况一样，大多数瘾君子面临的真正挣扎，其实是如何应对潜藏在背后的东西——
This is the part where it gets good, I promise. Over the last five years I've been doing this podcast, the three of you have systematically dismantled large parts of my brain that have been causing me pain. And like I said earlier, I just want to record it in clear posterity the following. Angela, you have this kindness, this deep well of empathy, seemingly with no bottom. Your ability to love and care about people you've never met as well as those you have is truly inspiring. The way you listen to Jenna, truly listen and feel her pain when she's in pain, or
那些我曾需要用毒品和酒精去麻痹的人格缺陷和创伤。我保证，接下来的部分会越来越精彩。在过去五年里我做这个播客的过程中，你们三个人系统性地拆解了我脑海中那些曾让我痛苦的大部分区域。正如我刚才所说，我只是想把以下内容清晰地记录在案留作纪念。安吉拉，你拥有这种善良，这种深不见底的同理心，仿佛永远没有底线。你爱和关怀从未谋面的人以及身边之人的能力，真的极其鼓舞人心。你倾听詹娜的方式——真正的倾听，并在她痛苦时感同身受她的痛苦，
remember things people have said for gifts later, or the way you check in on people who are going through a rough time, truly humbles me. Every time I interact with you, it fills my battery up to full. Which I realize must be draining to you, so I want to say thank you for that. You have too much love and empathy to be trapped in a candy jar. Jenna, there's an old joke slash meme that goes, why do weak men date strong women? And the answer is because someone has to tell our server, I ordered a Diet Coke and not a regular one, and it's not going to be me.
或者日后为了送礼而记住别人说过的话，或者你关切那些正经历艰难时期之人的方式，真的让我感到无比谦卑。每次与你互动，都会把我的电量充满。但我知道这一定很耗费你的精力，所以我想为此向你道谢。你拥有如此多的爱与同理心，不应该被困在一个糖果罐里。詹娜，有一个老笑话或网络迷因说的是：为什么脆弱的男人会和坚强的女性约会？答案是：因为总得有人去告诉服务员，“我点的是健怡可乐而不是普通可乐”，而这个人绝对不会是我。
I've learned so much about self-respect from you, from the way you don't allow yourself to be spoken down to, from the way you are clear about what you want out of life. And much like Angela, the way you don't allow your friends to be spoken to disrespectfully either. And also much like Angela, I have modeled so much in my life this last year after you. I recognize that you don't get to be that strong without the world trying to give you some shit, so I want to say thank you for persevering in your own life. Your ability to overcome obstacles without letting it affect your worldview is extremely inspiring. Kaz, you saved my life.
我从你身上学到了很多关于自尊的道理，从你不允许别人贬低你的态度，到你对生活中想要什么有着清晰目标的态度。而且就像安吉拉一样，你也同样不允许别人无礼地对待你的朋友。还有，和安吉拉很像的是，过去这一年我在生活中很多方面都以你为榜样。我意识到，一个人若想变得如此坚强，就势必得承受来自世界给予的种种刁难，所以我想感谢你在自己的生活中百折不挠。你克服障碍却不让其影响自己世界观的能力，真的极具启发性。卡兹（Kaz），你救了我的命。
When you started here, I was drowning in work. Your dedication to this podcast was immediately noticed. And much like Jenna and Angela, you've changed my life just by being you. There is a quiet confidence to you. You seem to have such a clear vision of who you are, you genuinely seem to like yourself. And as is the theme of this speech, I've modeled much of my daily sober life around you. Your work-life balance, music, playing, and basketball has inspired me to take up the cello again
当你刚开始在这里工作时，我正被繁重的工作淹没。你对这个播客的奉献精神立刻受到了大家的注意。而且就像詹娜和安吉拉一样，仅仅是通过做你自己，你就已经改变了我的生活。你身上有一种安静的自信。你似乎对“我是谁”有着如此清晰的愿景，你是真的打心底里喜欢自己。正如这段发言的主题一样，我把日常戒酒生活的很多方面都以你为模板。你的工作与生活平衡、弹音乐、打篮球，都激励着我重新拾起大提琴，
and sign up for several classes to make my own sober life as enjoyable day-to-day as possible. I could go on and on about the ways that you three have changed my life, but I'll wrap it up here and just say this. Everything that I am better for from having known you three comes from you guys overcoming your own battles in life.
并报名了好几个课程，好让自己的日常戒酒生活尽可能地充实愉快。关于你们三个人如何改变了我的生活，我可以滔滔不绝地说个没完，但我在这里做个总结，只想说：我因为认识你们三个人而变得更好的这一切，都源于你们克服了各自生活中的种种战斗。
You all have done so much inner work that it spills over and affects those around you. I just want to say that I see you and the work you've done. For the first time in a long time, I'm optimistic about my birthday and my life and my future because the three of you have taught me gratitude. That was the missing piece of my life. I live slower now, seeing and appreciating all that I have, and I have so much thanks to you three." There's a phrase that I hate from years of working in food service, and that phrase is, we are a family. Normally when you hear that, somebody's about to ask you to work
你们所有人都做了如此多的内在功课，以至于这些正能量溢出来，影响了周围的人。我只想说，我看到了你们，看到了你们所做的努力。长久以来第一次，我对我的生日、我的生活和我的未来感到乐观，因为你们三个人教会了我感恩。那是滋润我生活所缺失的拼图。现在的我生活节奏放慢了，能够看到并感激我所拥有的一切，多亏了你们三个人，我感激不尽。”餐饮服务业工作多年让我讨厌的一个词，那个词就是“我们是一家人”。通常当你听到这句话时，意味着有人马上要要求你
on a Saturday when you took the day off. But Jenna and Angela, I really hope that you guys are proud of yourselves. You've achieved something so rare in the performance space. You've truly created a family. I know your fans feel the same way as they are part of that family too. Thank you for letting me be part of this show and your family. And I love you. Sam. Sam. Sam, we love you so much.
在好不容易请假休息的周六去加班。但詹娜和安吉拉，我真心希望你们能为自己感到骄傲。你们在表演艺术领域取得了如此罕见的成就。你们真正创造了一个大家庭。我知道你们的粉丝也有同感，因为他们也是这个大家庭的一部分。谢谢你们让我成为这个节目和你们家庭的一部分。我爱你们。萨姆。萨姆。萨姆，我们太爱你啦。
We love you so much, Sam. Office Ladies is not Office Ladies without you, Sam. Yeah, Sam, I mean, this is why, this is why we needed you back, Sam. I'm unprepared with how to explain what you bring to us as well, but this, you're not left out of the magic that happens here, but also Sam, I have watched the grit and strength
我们太爱你啦，萨姆。没有你，萨姆，《办公室女士》就不再是《办公室女士》了。对，萨姆，我是说，这就是为什么，这就是为什么我们需要你回来，萨姆。对于如何解释你给我们带来的一切，我还没有做好准备，但这一点是——你并没有被排斥在这里发生的奇迹之外，而且萨姆，我看到了你投入到这种戒酒生活中的那股坚韧、力量
and resolve that you have gone into this sober living with. And it is also truly inspirational. I have watched you do silks. That's right. Cirque du Soleil silks. That's right. Cirque du Soleil silks. And I know that when you're doing that, I know the courage and vulnerability that it took for you to show up somewhere
和决心。这也同样真正地鼓舞人心。我看着你做绸缎吊床。没错。太阳马戏团的绸缎吊床。没错。太阳马戏团的绸缎吊床。我知道当你在做那个时，我知道你需要付出多大的勇气和脆弱感，才能去到一个
where you didn't know people to do an activity that was aiding your sobriety. And I just, I am so glad that you are giving yourself the care that you deserve because you deserve it. And we're just so happy that you're with us. Well, here's to another year, guys. Here's to another year. Here's to another year. Love you. We love you so much. Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
你不认识任何人的地方，去进行一项有助于你戒酒的活动。我只是，我真的很高兴你给予了自己应得的关爱，因为你实至名归。我们太高兴你能和我们在一起了。那么，为又一个年头干杯，各位。为又一个年头干杯。为又一个年头干杯。爱你们。我们太爱你们啦。我们的音频工程师是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins），我们的萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）是……我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科（Ainsley Bubbaco）。奥德赛（Wondery/Audacy）的执行制片人是莉娅·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《鲁珀特树》（Ruppertree）。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。